Rachel browsing the hands in the dark
about any Fantastic Four casting
announcements but the actress is ready
and willing should Marvel come calling I
haven't heard anything unfortunately but
I'm I'm here it's our last season I'm
about to be available yeah Rachel's
preparing to say goodbye to The
Marvelous Mrs maisel
do you have a handle on this at all
while chatting with E.T at the global
citizen Festival she teases what to
expect from the show's final season so
this is our last season that we're
shooting right now I think they can
expect as many twists and turns as ever
we've been so surprised scripture script
and so hopefully we can take audiences
on that ride with us too and that she
takes part in her ninth year at the
annual event Rachel explains how they're
making an impact around the world I'm so
continually inspired by This Global
citizen movement and it feels like it's
a much needed injection of Hope in such
an overwhelming and challenging time for
our Global Community I've been here for
so long because Global citizen
exemplifies this idea that even though
the issues we're facing as a globe as a
world are overwhelming they are you know
we are we've taken a hit in global
progress thanks to the pandemic we're
dealing with climate change you know
lack of access to Edge education
sanitation issues across the globe food
insecurity these issues are huge but
when we all do a little bit and when
we're committed to doing a little bit
every day we can make a huge difference
we can support partner organizations on
the ground doing the work every single
day it's important to get involved to do
something we've seen it in action here
on the global citizen stage we've seen
over the last 10 years that Global
Citizens been around world leaders
making commitments making Financial
commitments making commitments with
their policy in their home countries to
make them better we've seen it happen so
it is possible